in the last video i showed you that if
someone were to walk up to you and you
ask you
what is the
arc sine
whoops
of x
and you know so this is going to be
equal to who knows what this is just the
same thing as saying that look the sine
of some angle is equal to x and we
solved it a couple of cases in the last
example so using the same pattern let me
let me say this i could have also
rewritten this as the inverse sine
of x is equal to what these are
equivalent statements two ways of
writing the inverse sine function this
is more this is the inverse sine
function you're not taking this to the
negative one power you're just saying
the sine of what of so what question
mark what angle is equal to x we did
this in the last video so by the same
pattern if i were to walk up to you on
the street and i were to say
you know the tangent
of
the the inverse tangent of x is equal to
what you should immediately in your head
say oh he's just asking me he's just
saying look the tangent of some angle is
equal to x and i just need to figure out
what that angle is so let's do an
example so let's say i were to walk up
to you on the street there's a lot of
walking up on a lot of streets right
here let's see i would write and i would
say
u what is the arc
tangent
of minus one
or i could have equivalently asked you
what is the inverse tangent
of minus one these are equivalent
questions
and what you should do is you should in
your head if you don't have this
memorized you should draw the unit
circle and actually let me just do a
refresher of what tangent is even asking
us
the tangent of theta
this is just the straight up vanilla
non-inverse function tangent that's
equal to the sine of theta
over
the cosine of theta and the sine of
theta is is the y value on the unit
function on the unit
circle and the cosine of theta is the x
value
and so if you draw a line let me draw a
little unit circle here
so if i have a unit circle like that
and let's say i'm at some angle
let's say that's my angle theta
and this is my y my coordinate it's x y
we know already that the y value this is
the sine of theta let me scroll over
here
sine of theta and we already know that
this x value is the cosine
of theta so what's the tangent going to
be it's going to be this
distance
it's going to be this distance divided
by this distance or from your algebra 1
this might strike ring a bell because
we're starting at the origin from the
point 0 0 this is our change in y
over our change in x
or it's our rise over run
or you can kind of view the tangent of
theta or it really is as the slope of
this line
the slope
so you could write slope
is equal to the tangent of theta
so let's just bear that in mind when we
go to our example if i'm asking you
if i'm asking you and i'll rewrite it
here what is the inverse tangent of
minus 1 and i'll keep rewriting it or
the arc tangent
of minus 1 i'm saying what angle gives
me a slope of minus 1 on the unit circle
so let's draw the unit circle
let's draw the unit circle like that
and then i have my
axes
like that and i want a slope of minus
one a slope of 9 is 1 looks like this
it looks like that
right if it was like that it would be
slope of plus 1. so what angle is this
so in order to have a slope of -1 this
distance is the same as this distance
and you might already recognize that you
know this is a right angle so these
angles have to be the same and so it has
to be a 45 45 90 triangle this is an
isosceles triangle these two have to add
up to 90 and have to be the same so this
is 45 45 90. and if you know you're 45
45 9 actually you don't even have to
know the sides of it and we in the
previous video we saw that you know this
is going to be right here this
this distance is going to be squared of
2 over 2. so this coordinate in the y
direction is minus square root of 2 over
2 and this coordinate right here on the
x direction is square root of 2 over 2
because this length right there is that
so the square root of 2 over 2 squared
plus the square root of 2 over 2 squared
is equal to 1 squared but the important
thing to realize is a 45 45 90 triangle
so this
angle right here is well if you're just
looking at the triangle by itself you
would say that this is a 45 degree angle
but since we're going clockwise below
the x axis we'll call this a minus 45
degree angle
minus 45 degree so the the tangent of
minus 40 let me write that down
so if i'm in degrees and that tends to
be how i think so i could write the
tangent
the tangent of minus 45 degrees
it equals
this negative value minus square root of
2 over 2 over square root of 2 over 2
which is equal to -1
or i could write the arc tangent
of -1 is equal to -45 degrees now if
we're dealing with radians we just have
to convert this to radians so we
multiply that
times
we get pi radians
for every 180 degrees the degrees cancel
out you have 45 over 180 this goes four
times so this is equal to you have the
minus sign minus pi
over four
radians so the arc tangent of minus one
is equal to minus pi over 4 or the
inverse tangent
the inverse tangent of minus 1 is also
equal to minus pi over 4.
now you could say look if i'm at minus
pi over 4 that's there that's fine this
is this gives me a a value of minus 1
because the slope of this line is minus
1 but i could keep going around the unit
circle i could add 2 pi to this maybe i
could add you know i could add 2 pi to
this and that would also give me if i
take the tangent of that angle it would
also give me minus 1 or i could add 2 pi
again and it would again give me minus
1. in fact i could go to this point
right here and the tangent would also
give me -1 because the slope is right
there and like i said in the sine in the
inverse sine video you can't have a
function that has a one to many mapping
you can't you know tangent
tangent inverse of x can't map to a
bunch of different values you can't map
to minus pi over four
minus pi over four it can't map to
you know three what it would be three pi
over four
i don't know it would be
well i'll just say two pi
minus pi over four or four pi minus pi
it can't map to all of these different
things so i have to constrict the range
on the inverse tan function and we'll
restrict it very similarly to the way we
restricted the
the psi inverse sine range we're going
to strict it to the first and fourth
quadrants
so the the answer to your inverse
tangent is always going to be something
in these quadrants but it can't be this
point and that point because a tangent
function becomes undefined at pi over at
pi over two and at minus pi over two
because your slope goes vertical you
start dividing your change in x is zero
you're dividing your cosine of theta
goes to zero so if you divide by that
it's it's undefined so your range so if
i let me write this down
so if i have an inverse tangent of x i'm
going to
well what are all the values that the
tangent can take on so if i have the
tangent
of theta is equal to
x what are all the different values that
x could take on these are all the
possible values for the slope and that
slope can take on anything so x could be
anywhere between minus infinity
and positive infinity
x can pretty much take on any value but
what about theta
well i just said it theta you can only
go
from minus pi over 2 all the way to pi
over 2 and you can't even include pi
over 2 or minus pi over 2 because then
you'd be vertical
so then you say your so if i'm just
dealing with vanilla tangent not the
inverse the
domain
well that well the domain of tangent can
go
multiple times around so let me not make
that statement
but if i want to do inverse tangent so i
don't have a one to many mapping i want
to
cross out all of these i'm going to
restrict theta or my range
to be
greater than minus pi over 2 and less
than
positive
pi over 2. and so if i restrict my range
to this right here and i exclude that
point and that point then i can only get
one answer when i say what tangent of
what gives me a slope of minus -1 and
that's the question i'm asking right
there there's only one answer because if
i keep this one falls out of it and
obviously as i go around and around
those fall out of that valid range for
theta that i was giving you
and then you know just to kind of make
sure we did it right
we our answer was pi over four let's see
if we get that when we use our
calculator so the inverse
tangent
the inverse tangent of minus one
is equal to that let's see if that's the
same thing as minus pi over 4
minus pi over 4
is equal to that so it is minus pi over
4 but it was good that we solved it
without the calculator because it's hard
to recognize this as minus pi over four